THE RULES COMMITTEE MEETINGS FOR
THURSDAY.
AUGUST NINTH IS HEREBY COLD
ANGER.
OF PUGET BISON AUDIO VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
PAIN RELIEF AS ALSO BEING TOLD
LIES.
ABOUT SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL KUWAIT HERE CUNNINGHAM FEAR
CARILLO.
TORONTO HERE.
GALLAGHER HERE GRAYSON
[inaudible] FOR YES MAYES HERE
AS AREA.
PRESIDENT SALAS PRESENT WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA PROTECTORS
ADJUSTMENT.
RICHARD WE RESPECTFULLY ASK TO
REMOVE ITEM. ELEVEN ZERO ONE
THIRTY NINE AND ITEM.
TWELVE ZERO ONE TWO ONE AGENDA
AND HAVE A SEPARATE VOTE ON
THOSE ITEMS VERY GOOD AT THAT
WILL BE THE ORDER.
IT IS OUR MOTION REMAIN OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOSTLY SETTLE MOVE BY MS SENATE
OF OUR MISSION IS AIRING.
A MAN'S SEARCH FOR PEACE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE REMAINDER OF THE
A PRIMER FOR SENATE GENERAL
ARKANSAS CHEN.
COOLEY.
AYE COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. CARILLO AYE
CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE GALLAGHER.
AYE GALLAGHER AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE YES
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
LATEST HIGH MAYES I KNOW THERE
AND FIVE ON THE TIME NAZARIAN
AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON --
THAT MOTIONS PAST DECISIONS
PERHAPS IS OUR MOTION THIS YEAR
ONE THREE NINE MISTER MONEY.
IS OUR MOTION THE FAMILIES
RESOLUTION YES ON MY VERY
RESTORED.
MISS CARILLO SECULAR MOTIONS
AARON --
MANAGE CERTAIN PIECE CULTURAL.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CARILLO I CARILLO
AYE CERVANTES AYE CERVANTES AYE
GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER NO
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE YEAH
KAMLAGER-DOVE ADVOCATES MAYES
NOT VOTING FLOWS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON MUCH
APPROACHES OKAY THAT MOTION IS
PASSED.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE MISTER
PARENTS S..
ZERO ONE FIFTY ONE MOVE ON HIS
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
SECONDED BY [inaudible]
MR -- ZERO
THAT SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
COOLEY AYE.
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE YES
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AYE MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING NAZARIAN.
I WAS VERY AN AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON.
OF THAT MOTIONS PASS AND THIS
WILL SQUEEZE WHO TURNED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH